hello everybody and welcome to a brand
video today's gonna be my first video
recorded in Nicaragua and for those who
know that is in Central America I got
here about a week ago very nice yeah so
actually recording a video in a hostel
room it's pretty awkward to be honest
but we're gonna do it so we have for you
today is 10 and grand exchange tips and
tricks to help you improve your profit
these will be actual methods or tiny
little techniques that you use they're
not gonna be like overall general tips
or things that won't actually help you
directly I just hope you enjoy and let's
get started alright coming in at number
1 is gonna be page set combinations so
if you didn't know you can actually buy
all four of any God page set on the gran
exchange in a set form so let's say the
book of la page set is gonna be you well
but one mill and it's going to contain
the four pages our mill page one two
three and four
to create it however most people aren't
going to go ahead and buy the pages
individually but going by to set so
because of this you can actually get a
very good margin on page sets to be able
to kanji tracker at the air sponsor of
mine so go check them out there will be
a link in the description for that it's
a nice way of showing it so with the
unholy page book contains amarak pages
one through four and has a margin of 61
k not only have to do is go and buy all
the pages at a cheap price so let's go
have a look at the end the holy book
page set so let's if we can buy it for
open buy it for 16 and 19 so decent will
itself back for the money right now
obviously i'm not going to be making
money on this particular flip but i'm
just trying to show you an example here
thank god I haven't tried using the
calculator on my Windows 10 computer
this thing is huge
anyway so we're gonna go claim all the
offers and basically just subtract the
price you can sell the page sets for and
then you subtract its price you can buy
the pages for in an ideal world you
would make 76 K per paycheck combination
now they've a buy limit of five I
believe
so it's worth throwing an 80 K flip very
good now coming in number two is item
set combinations it's pretty much the
exact same thing is page sets however
certain armorer items have set so you
can make most notably barrows items are
particularly good for this however we
can do with ruin item sets or gussets
from an armor and stuff like that but
doesn't look nearly as well I'm not
going to show you this example because
it's essentially
the exact same thing you look on gee
tracker they usually have a couple near
the top because usually one of them is
pretty good look at this Kirill's armor
set right now is showing a bit of 300k
profit for items that combination and
you can do actually ten of these that's
not right ten limit per four hours so
you make a ton of money doing this this
would be a three mil flip theoretically
coming in and number three is actually
gonna be decanting crushed bones that's
kind of the best word I have for it but
basically we're gonna do is buy and
again I don't need to crush you
currently items like to superior dragon
bone tend to work really well I'm not
sure if the margin is still gonna be
good or not haven't checked it yet but
let's just go have a quick look so
currently there isn't really a margin
with this but just so you know in the
future an NPC called Wesley or Weasley
will actually be able to grind bones for
you instantly and you can bring in a
stack of noted bones if you want for 50
coins on an item a couple weeks ago is
getting a 200 to 250 GP margin on
superior dragon bones however sometimes
it can work for a desert don't Warren or
other items but you will need 50 GP or
more and probably you want to look
around 100 now you can do dragon skills
in the dragon skill dust a bird's nest
however I don't think that would ever be
profitable wheeze a very useful NPC that
a lot of people don't know about he is
an artist so it's a bit of a trek but
told it where is it coming in at number
four is decanting potions now this is
something that I do quite frequent is
buying potion three doses and decanting
them into potion four doses now it's a
little tricky to find the margin but
pretty much what you do is you buy and
sell a super attack potion three
and you get that then you're gonna buy
the potion for doze and know the price
that you could sell that for so
currently we're gonna able to sell it
for three hundred and thirty now here's
a little bit of a tricky margin to
calculate but it's really not that bad
so we have to do is you have to take the
price that you bought the super tak
potion for head which is in turn to me
the price you can sell that and multiply
it by 0.75 since we need to count the
potions
you're gonna lose 25% of the potions but
you're gonna gain a super attack potion
floors you need to multiply it by 0.75
to get an even margin and then there's
gonna subtract the price that you can
buy the mat which is 204 to get your
margin and you can do 2,000 of these
every four hours so it's gonna be an 87
K flip these are extremely quick and I
would recommend doing it okay come on
the number 5 is kind of niche 1 you
can't do very frequently however
occasionally it can come in handy and
that is removing poison from items now
works really well with arrow keys or
stuff like that
where you can do a multiple items in one
go because it will remove all 10,000
poison charges from 10,000 arrows just
in one go so it only takes a second now
right now it's not profitable and it
isn't often however sometimes when
you're looking at the prices the rune
arrow P will actually be cheaper than
your broom arrow what you do is buy
10,000 rune arrow keys maybe it'd be
cheaper you remove it with the cleaning
cloth instantly and then you sell off
just a regular rune arrows for more now
you can do this with Divi esses other
items have poison on it not something
you can do all the time but something to
keep in mind come in at number 6 is
gonna be doing the Barrows repair now
basically the way this works is you buy
totally degraded barrows items and you
repair it either in a play around host
or from Bob and Lumbridge I've used Bob
Breen and viewed losing out a little bit
of your profit G trackers and they stool
for this as well that I'm looking at
right now but let's have a look at the
trails leather top so you do is you buy
the quills leather top to 0 and I'm
checking the margin right now again
knocking making money off this they
really don't sell that much so it's a
bit risky to try the buy one let's have
a look at it on G tracker inside ins
that are this slow they're pretty
accurate on GE tracker normally so we're
looking at about 1885 and if we look at
how much the krills leather top is when
it has been repaired
okay we just bought for 2,500 oh my god
I think we messed that up a bit
that was a pig in the background don't
remind that too much
yeah so you can see that stuff like this
can give you really good margins
although I just lost more Kiana's item
fat down it really safe flip however we
definitely wanna leave this in like
overnight because it's very slow
next up come on number seven is breaking
down Zorro items into Zorro scales you
just buy think three or four different
items at the server time helm on D
certain time and visit if you want the
tanzanite thing as well as magic thing
basically you have to multiply the price
of Zeller scales by 20,000 because that
is how many solar scales are gonna get
by decanting essential or dismantling
one of the items so let's look at the
magic Fang right now so 2900 is when we
bought it for but hopefully we get it
for cheaper for around twenty eight six
six now if we have a look at the price
of our scales right now we're looking to
sell them for 150 150 times twenty two
thousand is gonna be three mil actually
per item will actually go buy some of
these after right now that's about 150 k
profits I'm right coming at number eight
is gonna be crafting podium wards or the
podium chart one two and three so this
one's gonna differ a little bit from the
other methods because you actually need
to go into wilderness for this one we'll
leave a video link for this because I am
literally dying in this hostel room I'm
getting so hot I'm so we don't really
I'm enough time in this video to go over
it exactly but have done this in a video
before and I will leave a link in the
description for that essentially just by
the odium sharp one two and three on the
grand exchange and go into the deep
wilderness craft into northern ward or a
malediction ward and now the margins can
be huge like 500k however the items are
very slow to buy but it's something to
keep in mind coming at number nine is
crafting eternal boots primordial boots
or occasion boots now the kicker here is
you do need to think 55 room crafting to
make the combination which is extremely
random and you will need a pretty solid
cash stack to do this however all you
need to do is buy the eternal crystal
and infinity boots and combine them
together it's really easy I can give ATK
margins hundred K margins and I didn't
do buy pretty quickly some of them more
than others though I'm coming at number
10 is gonna be crafting toxic blow pipes
or toxic tridents out of the tanzanite
thing or the magic thing
now you need a crafting level for this
but it's extremely easy to do all you
have to do is buy the magic Fang on the
grand exchange and use a chisel on it
now you can get usually but 50k per item
on this is still a very good method to
do when you get a chance anybody guys
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
don't forget to leave a like and I will
see you some were cooler were will not
literally die in here without the fan on
anyway see you guys later